hey can hear me Oh Kenny can we hear us
hello we've done it I'm just I hope I
hope that how's it going everybody sorry
about that something got changed on the
settings and I had to figure out what
was up wonderful
anyway let's start this over happy
community Fridays ven hey welcome
everyone we're here to play some mortal
kombat cuz night wolf came out yeah I
hope you will enjoy my dumb insane
gesturing for the first like two minutes
but more importantly if you would like
to join us we're currently hosting a
room on the PlayStation 4 home
entertainment console version of Mortal
Kombat xi Reina's GameSpot but with a
three because it disconnected me before
and that room that I made before still
exists and we've got people coming in
excellent just as a heads up wait a
little bit of night wolf now guy good
with him I haven't really played too
much of night wolf from the other games
but uh if you're good if you're bad it
doesn't matter
we'll all just excited to play games
yeah we're just excited playing people
were asking if we were gonna replace the
Mortal Kombat after night wolf came out
because we had a really fun time playing
Mortal Kombat last time we did it so
people want us to do it again
so we're gonna start off here taking on
abundant I believe my win uh my wind
chance is three percent so well uh I'll
see you then goes all right we'll just
we'll start it off with a good combo
exhibition I feel like so what console
are we on we're on ps4 yes a sound elody
all right so I'm gonna probably also we
should mention we we talked about this
beforehand mm-hmm might be a little bit
of a shorter stream just because we have
a lot of folks from other offices in and
they it might be kind of filing out and
leaving yeah people are leaving so I
think we wanted to make sure we didn't
miss anyone so it'll be a little bit of
short Friday stream unfortunately guys
but we're gonna try and get as many
matches in as possible got that classic
skin
let's get that volume like that uh
slower yeah yeah cool um I'm gonna put
the pit back up once the match starts
and then all I like this this thing that
displays what moves each person has in
their loadout that's really good
do you guys know where you're talking
about of course we do I mean yeah always
every time a hundred percent I stand
against every injustice all right let's
see where we're at you don't need to
hold back or anything you can you can do
what you got to do okay I'm ready for
the the Sonia hurt I wonder if she's as
good as she she was before I remember it
being a bit of a thing but I'm ready for
it
all right all right we're getting warmed
up or getting warmed up and feeling at
you Oh God
there we go
trying to remember all my a my cool like
little combo things I got we're the
worst I don't know for the worst we're
definitely not the best but uh you know
people light our you're not allowed in
here yeah the only possibility in our
streams no why is everyone available do
this server we were having a good fight
oh ah all right so that means we're
probably gonna have to well maybe we can
rejoin the room we'll see well we'll see
where it goes man rip we got it at the
run back
ripping rip indeed I don't know if
there's like like yeah thing go on cuz
that's the second time we've seen that
happen I mean I hope it's not our
connection but I don't I don't know why
it would be searching for available so
the problem is we probably can't join
the GameSpot there it's right there but
something tells me am i able to join
that shine it cuz it keeps happening
where it kicks you out of your own
little thing is room people have not
shoot it won't let us join oh my god
dude
but why another one it did that before
too like that's really dumb this one's
gonna be hmm
GameSpot with the four
there's like three GameSpot rooms going
on right now pick one of them will be
there and one of them yeah so now the
new room that we've made is GameSpot
with a four so join up on that and go
through all the lessons job first one in
the room let's do it
alright thanks guys sorry for for this
yeah well well well crime thank you for
doing that in the chat just keeping
people up to date with where the where
the room is being honest you aren't half
bad I I'll take that thank you not great
but night wolves means pretty busted
good reminds me a Saibot Spacek common
string he seems pretty strong just in
like a little bit that I've played him
GTA RNG
no we do not have any consoles to give
out if you keep asking I'm gonna have to
you Pacino time I want to do it people
but I know how I do it but can't wait
for Borderlands 3 yeah I'm pretty
excited for that and hyped up for it
myself there's a lot of good games
coming out all right here we go
let's do it see you guys normally
consoles is that what I heard here we go
hand banana don't die on you don't you
start with me man
it's got a lot of like just really good
like combos that do a lot of hits in mix
up a lot at least from what what I'm
kind of pulling together here he's got
that one for hit one that kind of does
like an overhead at the end and that's
been like pretty good yeah as a heads up
for anyone who's fighting me that's
probably when I'm in like 90% of the
time YouTube oh you know you show up now
that you hear about that's what this
three consoles hmm whoo
Tyra Brown wants to know what's your
longest combo you've done with Nightwolf
me personally honestly not that high it
might be like maybe seven hits because I
accidentally hit the right string yeah I
mean we're not
oh no I jumped right into it
we like dabble back with this game but I
haven't been like keeping up with it you
know ever since it came out I'm a
regular yeah like we're playing with a
couple of people in the office and I was
like alright cool I'm gonna pull out
Johnny Cage he's my dude that I put the
most time at and I was still able to do
some of the stuff but yeah I forgot how
to do all like scorpion stuff and
they'll set up all right
I saw that counter coming I think I
think us being good at the game which I
appreciate mr. keepo and I think it's
cuz just our general like knowledge of
fighting games is what's keeping us
afloat yeah we're we're not like rather
than specific Mortal Kombat 11 skills
are our main thing is that we're
definitely not like professionals but
now we're fans of fighting games play
Cyrax please if I could I would tie
racks ain't in this game kidney pie on
the Nintendo switch I do not have a
switch copy Omega I think the only
person I know that has one is and maybe
the people who got to record stuff like
Max house 1 because he was capturing
with it that's right that's right does
the first one of the day and we got a
fatality so it's not even that bad
Monster Hunter Friday soon says Brendan
yeah man do very exciting I was thinking
about that the today on the walk to work
I was thinking man monster honor will
probably bring back Monster Hunter
Fridays soon hey yeah
good fight though thought I had it for a
bit and then oh you listen you what
let's do a rematch because there are
people still kind of finally sure sure
I'm down get that run back let's get a
run back there that
how's y'all Friday going meme Z says
they're still waiting on spawn
yeah spawns a good one spawns real cool
I'm still holding out for them to reveal
they got a thing coming up real soon I
think for the next characters and I
still think ash Williams has a big
chance of being a did you complete your
daily apex legend challenges yet I
haven't kept up with apex legends in a
while I imagine Tay has been keeping up
with that stuff
I'm adherents not good things about
those ladies I heard about that too like
there's some weirdness with you gotta
like be really on point where you got to
spend like ridiculous amount of money
where's the anime fighters at we played
Dragon Ball last week right you max
played that yeah it was a very good time
so that was cool I asked I mentioned
earlier Monster Hunter when we do
Monster Hunter it'll be on ps4 our
promise we made forever ago that we
would be permanently switching to the PC
that Capcom had to prove us wrong by not
putting out the expansion on PC at the
same time this ps4 so hmm greetings from
Chile Wow
thanks all the way from Chile I always
like when I see people in the chatter
like I'm from you know yeah like maybe
one time I got some for like Saudi
Arabia like it's somewhere ok ok
somewhere in the Middle East that's red
I remember being like wow that's awesome
thank you for joining
yeah like hearing hearing people from
all sorts of different places is still
wild yeah that's cool I love that
ooh well I thought I thought you're
gonna throw me up under the cactus for a
second all right talk about Citadel's
and down one of those okay she is she's
supposed to be next I don't know if
she's next I think the people who are
next to the other two that haven't been
announced yet okay mom cuz they they've
got like a an event thing like actually
scheduled no no idea when some bells
come oh man you else is from the
Dominican Republic so cool they've got
the second fatality that's fine it's
fatalities are fatalities I'm here for
me the way but uh I've lost a both
matches that's come back in and check
out but good fights though the next one
got a really good Jade you got cool cool
combo things down add text see I was
supposed to add text at some point goob
and I totally forgot oh no not select
new fighter I need to quit Tyler's from
New Zealand I think everyone in the chat
saying where they're from yeah I am
school alright who we got in here now
crime once again putting in the the room
number which probably add that on the
story another thing yeah we need a
alright Rising Sun let's do this thing
and if you guys want to join again we're
on PlayStation 4 we've got a room called
the game spot with a four in it not any
one of the other two that we've been
kicked out of because of the server's
doing it but we're here I can add some
text maybe someone from Michigan same my
dear I'm gonna hop out of the got a full
can for a second hard some text do that
thing so we have a night wolf mirror
match up maybe Liu Kang's cool that's
that's it's all good let's just let's do
a random stage here
the hourglass is it all caps the room
name ah yes
oh there's no there's no a well you see
this elite speakers ah looking good
put shaggy in people are saying no
really you're still on that all right I
guess all right call him bicycle kick
right away I want it
give me that bicycle kick no oh yeah I'm
feeling the pressure right now
oh no the the rolls and everything just
oh there it is Luke hangs really cool in
this game yeah this may be one of my
favorite like versions of him I I like
the story load the 1000 definitely just
good big boys there it is oh man I
thought I could I thought I could just
raw do a thing there and I was
definitely wrong hmm hello welcome for
joining howdy guys your face cam
oh sorry I took the face came off for a
sec to add the text now we got face cam
at text so there it is and you tality
crime no longer he needs to constantly
remind everyone where the room is
although we really appreciate that crime
if you want to still do it you're more
than welcome to let's do a student run
back I'm ready to get worked again good
fight coffin wants to know if your
optimism has a limit you spoiler
probably not yeah you you one of the
most optimistic people I'm it I don't
know there was a point in time where I I
used to get kind of upset at stuff and
then I realized like oh okay week later
I don't even think about that like
what's the what's the point you know I
just wanna play video games and have a
good time so I did manage to beat the
story mode
point and I'm a little bummed out that
we didn't get what that kind of reveal
is at the end of it well the story mode
the story looks for manual oh oh like
the arcade mode yeah Wow
do you want to spoil what what was there
not maybe I don't hide him to the shy
you can tell me it's too big of a thing
we can say it it's fine because the
whole thing I guess was night well if
you don't know is that it's night wolf
isn't one person it's a it's a man told
it's handled right and night this night
wolf at the end of story mode is given
the choice of either remaining night off
to protect his tribe or becoming like
the keeper of time right and the the
spirit told him hey you should you know
reset time and set everything right and
we'll pass the mantle off the Samanas
and they show at the end of it like a
female night girl oh that would be real
badass like I'm out of it real cool that
I've been a cool alternate or something
man that's cool so this is this night
was supposed to be a different uh night
wolf than the other one
yeah make sense how that one died the
the interesting thing about this one is
his Mane is gray cloud which is like ah
smoke oh I got a mercy interesting
I'll just do this in a see where it goes
I mean I mean it wouldn't make as much
sense in this game but like you could do
kind of what injustice to did where they
would have those like premium skins that
would actually make it a different
character oh shoot so like I think it
was like what like Captain Cold
yeah I had like an alternate skin that
turn him into mr. freeze and it's like
the same move set but it like makes
sense because it's like a different
character you guys do any Xbox games and
that's crime pointed out we like doing a
halo yeah we do I like doing those Halo
games that's what we haven't done in a
while we've been waiting for them to do
the test flight stuff on peace yeah we
wanted to get into like some of that
people you see stuff but that seems like
they keep delaying it every time I see
an update relating to that it's like
yeah the delay in it driving issues
granted you know they're trying to put
all those games on PC I'm sure that's a
very daunting task I don't know how big
that team is ooh they're right because I
imagine the majority of 343 is working
on Halo Infinite so that probably is a
lot but you know I'm excited for that
there was that big news thing they
announced no no and another brute
channel of you tality on you oh I got
the nice you're Luke hang it's very good
those were very good fights but the they
had they had that update where they were
going to there are more people in the
room ready for a match all right let's
get let's maybe keep it rotating since
this is it gonna be a short stream but
no they announced that they're going to
be adding all of the custom like forge
maps and main types from previous Halo
games like the into the Master Chief
collection so they're gonna take like
all of the ones that people have taken
accept and uploaded into the servers on
the 360
90% 99% oh yes that's like we're not
gonna say 100 just because we can't say
with a hundred percent certainty that
everything is gonna be fine like you can
control Wright's battery but 99%
everybody apparently is gonna be 2.6
million things like brought over to the
Master Chief collection between Halo 3 4
in reach which is crazy
well those those you Philip uh very good
I was into it and I appreciate the
brutality exhibition - yes crime so
they're manually converting all of the
ones from like the 360 to the MCC it's
gonna be a one-time thing so if you
still have your like custom maps and
modes that you made from the like 360
era and you want those to be brought
over to the MCC without having to remake
them then you should right now hop on a
year old save import them and then I
think I forget what day it is but they
have mentioned there's gonna be a day
where they're then gonna move everything
over so that's uh that's cool
where's Jessa McDonald she is here in
the office actually mm-hmm it's funny
every time someone asks we're always
like ah she's in Australia and this was
here she's actually here in the office
she's off doing some work right now but
yeah we've uh busy you don't know we
we've had everyone all the international
people here in the office this week it's
part of like a big gamespot get-together
and it's been a ton of fun I'm sorry I'm
just talking this you're getting your
you're trying to do your fight it's all
good miss Jess haven't seen anything
from her in a while Jess still does some
stuff she uh she's a dog video she's a
really great video on plague tale oh
that was excellent
if you hadn't seen that you should go
check that out so yeah she's she's still
hopping in and doing videos you'll
probably see her this year on extra life
again she oh he just loves doing extra
life
not to not to get like too far ahead but
that is a couple months away and I've
started to started to think about that a
little bit no I was like oh cool I'm
blocking it's definitely gonna be the
grab no I'm open
[Music]
that's right we'll do it we'll do the
run back yeah on a mercy though oh you
know what this is actually a good
opportunity to plug hey if you want to
hear more Jess you should check out
today's episode of GameSpot
after dark because she is on it it's
true also I appreciate all the mercies
that are happening so if that is what
you're interested in please
go check that out it's our second
episode of our brand new podcast games
but after dark for those who do haven't
heard of it you can go find it out on
all the available we're all fine
podcasts are stored took a little while
for it to get on iTunes because I was
being kind of and read like a book I'm
so sorry you just keep doing that
confusing the podcast feel bad so second
episode
it's got Jake it's got Rob handler II
and it's got just from Australia and
then Dave Jewett from the UK as crime
said it's on Spotify it's on like I
think like a Google store like Google
Play it's on iTunes
today's episode should go up at one
wasn't animal flight of the run back
doing how to be run backs are we moving
on cuz I would say move on just so we
can get everyone in I want to make sure
we get everyone in was a very good fight
your Jax is fantastic and I'd love to do
a rematch but there are more people to
fight I've got to get my ass handed to
you by more people I haven't met my
getting my ass beat quota yet but we're
gonna get there mmm yep so if you want
to go on check out that podcast 1 p.m.
our time today so about an hour and a
half that should be going live for
everyone check it out far did you guys
make it a TiVo I made it to my living
room
yeah which apparently sounds like it
might be a better situation look
apparently there was a case of
yeah though here the office to know
about that
should we tell them Oh Michael knows
about it / Persian knows this person
does max now should we max might not I
don't know they were saying something
out it takes 21 up to 21 days for it to
show up something like hey max yeah yeah
I should get that checked out the cycle
free night what was not free but my
night wolf is free because I like that
it's a good way to put that all right
let's go K no I'm ready I'm not ready
you got at least get wounded I actually
spent time memorizing both of his
fatalities I've gotta I've gotta find a
way there we go joy woo how do you feel
about jacks as a fighter he's easy to
pick up and easy to master is he hard to
pick up and hard to master I feel like
he's he's got a lot of cool stuff just
kind of at the beginning he's got a lot
of cool stuff the beginning he's really
fun he's his punch oh I've got some
things happen he's got a really
satisfying punch yeah some of his like
facing metal sound of his arm real good
I would say he's not I don't know if
he's easy to pick up necessarily but he
I don't think he's very hard to pick up
oh my god Kato you woke up yikes
is that a gun star club black yes
what's the podcast about well typically
the podcast is about it's kind of we
talk about what we've been playing and
then we talk about sort of like latest
news stuff and then we answer user
questions as well that people we have an
email that people can submit questions
to you as far as one cast this week I'm
actually not a hundred percent sure I
was on the I was not on the podcast this
week so I can't say but I'm sure it's
about all sorts of fantastic stuff I do
believe
Rob talks a little bit about no man's
sky beyond the new update that just came
out the other day with the VR support I
believe he's talked about that a little
bit beyond is broken so I've been
messing a little bit with the VR stuff
it's uh it's neat but it's a little I
gotta mess with it more apparently the
whole like update is still kind of not
[Applause]
know fell short just last second all the
mercies happening again are we shuffling
oh no experimental passionate still
isn't really work good you're on PC
crime I prayed the PC version is uh if I
seen the worst I'm gonna feel real bad
I heard the PC versions in worse shape
than the oh no than the console version
I have to I have to do it at least once
do it I have to do at least do one
fatality yeah I should have mercy but
you you you made this possible
she looks like an at least walk away
today say oh man you've upset him I'm
sorry I I just want to let you know I
appreciate you how dare you
I'm the worst no you know what because
I'm gonna do the I'm gonna do the run
back you get a run back because I stole
that it shouldn't have been like that
shoulda went down that way soundtracks
is damn that's cold
it was it's cold man all right this one
this one's the real one
okay so you can you can take your win
[Laughter]
all right we got we got own cages this
time around
Jax is very hard who's the hardest
better to get good at playing oh no what
do you say is the most difficult
Mortal Kombat fighting oh I don't know
if there's any character mortal primate
that stands out as particularly
difficult it like I feel like I could
probably play almost anyone on the
roster if I gave them the time so for me
maybe it's more of like an aesthetic
calling yeah like an aesthetic thing
like I don't think I'd ever play etrian
cuz I just don't like any of their stuff
right so Mortal Kombat so he's fairly
accessible I was right there for that
grab meet a burn Bob Jones joining in
the chat what's up what up Bob good to
see ya
no no oh that's good the cane was really
cool as can I was good
I like all of his oh my god right at the
last second I like all the changes they
made to like how he has more
mid combo grabs all know what the spit
they also don't really juggle
good morning everyone that's disgusting
and you got a rule got a brutality so
there's a good trade-off mean just hey
he goes go to the bathroom because
sometimes you got it like after I
explode a man's head by but she was such
a gross boy yeah my god there we go
we've set everything correct everything
is right we fixed it good fights all
right Kano was fantastic all right guys
we're gonna go for about another 20
minutes sorry today is a short stream as
we mentioned a lot of if we have the you
the UK and the Australian people even
other people to like yeah Chris prayer
came all the way from Connecticut I
believe but yeah we have basically
everyone from gamespot here in the SF
office so because of that we're going to
cut early go this dream a little bit
really because a lot of people are
leaving around noon and we want to make
sure we get to say goodbye
I'd hate for them to leave while I'm
like streaming Mortal Kombat but this
also isn't the last time we're streaming
Mortal Kombat No we'll definitely we'll
definitely do it again you can guarantee
that when more characters come out we'll
be back as soon as ash Williams happens
I'm just very very here for you know
let's go to the Fight Club you've been
to the Fight Club yet take it to the
bone temple later on I have to dark
party heck yeah more combat Mondays but
but Monster Hunter Mondays that turned
into Monster Hunter Fridays we should
have just kept Monster Hunter Mondays
but kept it on a Friday I know right
just to like completely mess with
everything
so whatever actually you know what maybe
frost is kind of a more difficult
character because I can't reach me at
her she is a little little tough so when
I was about to say whenever I see a
frost I feel like they know what they're
doing more than most people because it
takes takes some some kind of a more
thought I think at least on my end
cuz I I have no idea how to make their
stuff and now I'm in my own head right
now and I need to I need to sort this
out
get this out of here no one wants to
mess with that is it too late to join
it's not too late to join you can still
join we're gonna be going for about
another 20 minutes
we've been rotating through the the
lobby at a relatively quick pace to try
to make sure we can play with everyone
please don't forget John and get your
your beatdowns in oh man
human males to set around give me major
and [ __ ] and tain't enchantress Jesus
vibes from injustice - yes she it
probably feels the most like an in like
an injustice character she's got that
Miss watch justice like fatalities yeah
she feels she feels very inspired by
like injustice hormonal combats feel
like you're setting up for a thing you
know what you're doing yeah yeah they're
trying to they're trying to do a thing
yeah yeah there yep yep they're like I'm
trying to pull off a ah dang brutality
that ain't cool
the mercy happens again maybe we're
alive that's okay look we got one
fatality going so I was talking here
there when I saw this but I feel like at
least for me one of the worst fatal
blows is his Frost's because of how many
times like icicles go into like people's
eyes la I stopped in this huh because
that happened to me once oh god that is
no good the feeling of what it was like
to have the ice go into my eye just
hearing that all I I can't ever forget
it and so whenever I see her her fatal
blow I'm like no thank you
I've been there no thank you but good
fight is a very good Friday good fight
huh and I appreciate the mercy again as
holy Tyler brown thank you for joining
us really appreciate it man come back
come back next week yeah
and if you are enjoying yourself please
do think about some journal jean-luc and
I stream every Friday mm-hmm we do you
try to play with you guys I promise it's
not always me playing Nightwolf I don't
know what we'll do next week because
next week is um a well it's Gamescom but
there's nothing else like big no big
games coming out right
that I can think of august's been a
weird month he's gotta been noting me
with mirror match love it it's been like
a weird month we're eventually more like
a ton of stuff comes out like right at
the end of the month mail says thank you
guys for reading chat it often feels
like when I tuned GameSpot live stream
chat getting north so thank you both
well sorry you feel that way hopefully
we read the chat I know that I want to
call anyone out there if they're not
doing their job but it's a very
important thing to me to read the chat
when we do stream because like white why
do you why stream if you're not going to
talk to the people Blair Witch August
30th mmm that one that's not a good
community Friday streams of that is a
that's still a fun stream idea it's like
icing boy although the studio lights we
both do the same horror games for a
stream are like there's a reason why
that that stuff successful as like
YouTube Let's Plays because it's fun to
watch that stuff you like our night wolf
tech is very on par with another cuz we
did try to do the same thing at the very
beginning a lot of people the chat have
been saying it's just a general sense
when I've been hearing is that night
wolf is very easy to pick up yeah
which says volumes about how good the
people are leaving fighting gooses makes
you tell HR in advance before we do a
horror stream yes please get Curt on
yeah
he's referencing a we did a five nights
at freddy VR video cuz they added they
did like be our version of five minutes
of Freddy's and we got Curt on and I
felt bad it was apparently his first
life video he was like officially on for
GameSpot and he is uh I've never seen
someone react so viscerally to anything
in my shirt is just anything in my life
holy crap use a real good sport about it
but I felt real
real bad well that that that move when
it rocks like that is just almost too
much Alexander that's a good point I do
think that's probably why people play
their watch a lot of horror games
because they probably would never plan
themselves and they want to see it I've
got to do one not do that mercy I got it
I gotta bring it in so why would I do
that that's such a stupid move why but
why you took the mercy no I hit my fatal
blow from fullscreen when I'm like oh I
know he's got to be right on top of them
get out of there Oh No Oh No nice nice
bring it back we're gonna back and forth
do it again do it again all right
since we did that one we got to do the
other one yeah course Scottie this was
gross this one's disgusting uh not not
the highest he roasts gusting fatalities
definitely really high that's real real
gnarly there's definitely worse but oh
can you imagine the amount of hatred
you'd have to have to be like let's cut
this guy's jaw off and I'm a ripoff it's
fun oh thanks man thank you for the
negative mirror match thank you very
much of course happy hey man have you
two thanks for joining backup we're
gonna catch so maybe this no no they got
cut off before you came in you really
appreciate him at a good time all right
who do we got next
we got uh the Skywalker was in the tasks
and earlier if they wanted to play jump
down today would they get on maybe
possibly hmm I don't think we've fought
I think we fought Frankie I don't think
we fought from hell
cool so I'll throw a challenge to
Frankie I think Frankie someone we just
fought oh shoot and realize what I was
doing I'm like I'm pretty sure we just
fought Frankie Frankie again
let's do from hell if we haven't fought
my man well they're doing a match well
let's do Rising Sun come over do you
want to wait what Rising Sun we'll
probably beat me fast enough to catch
from how come as we come out so well
we'll get the run back with Rising Sun
all uh-oh play I'll play Johnny Cage
just to mix it up allowing voice chat
extreme he's really asking for trouble
we typically don't allow it I didn't
realize that it actually default put it
on on like the lobby so yeah normally
that's the kind of thing that we would
we would turn off however well we
appreciate you guys people have been
really polite and nice so I haven't seen
a reason to turn it off yet go for the
lowest window just challenge yourself
they all they all have over a 50% chance
to win it's mmm I do like that
like I said even if there are people who
are really good like seeing someone else
play at that level is really fun and
maybe I can learn some things like I'll
probably learn something from this point
for sure are you guys gonna do a halo
Master Chief Edition on Steam when it
comes out absolutely that we will oh
that move is
wild every time I'm trying to remember
this is it one of these and then you
kind of like I got my glasses throw
still cuz of course I do
so nervous because I feel like I'm
alright with Johnny Cage feeling it oh
no Johnny doe by the way everyone we're
gonna be going for about 10 more minutes
so we cannot wear it like we said in
short stream today so if you're
interested in playing with us try and
get in real quick hopefully we can get
you in do you guys have any insider
information on mass chief collections
release no wish I did
yeah wish I did we don't even I don't
even access to that flight stuff I
signed up for it but didn't get in well
I think we haven't had any yet I thought
they did no really it like it's move
delayed delayed been delayed boom ah
geez okay well hey that's why I wanted
to do it all I can't wait for injustice
3 to come out I mean injustice to
apparently did pretty well for them just
as a great game good yeah so I wouldn't
be opposed to that for sure but I'm also
kind of curious uh what well I think
like they'll always have a Mortal Kombat
game I would love to see them maybe like
a monster game yeah like maybe maybe
step back from injustice and like do
another thing that monster game we
always talked about
I love the mercies every I don't want to
say every game should have that because
I feel like it might diminish it but
it's it's a feature that I really
appreciate yeah
oh that kick leaves just so open I'll
just say it better be a brutality heck
yeah
oh nice Johnny that's fine all his
head's splitting to LMD ego
oh man it was a good fight though I like
that a lot that's really I may have lost
his Johnny and I might I might feel that
in my soul but it was a good fight
either way I looked up the background
says Liu Kang but then it's a night wolf
on his little debts that stays cool
that's it Zelda master Johnson's what up
friends what up how's it going pretty
good we are I answered your question
hell isn't in a match against that means
you gotta fight yeah let's fight them
let's not fight - we got eight minutes
so we can probably do this match maybe
they'll one other oh no oh yeah well
we'll do a match after him who we fight
who's gonna fight what's the plan
where's it going where did they come
from where do they go put cotton eyed
Joe and flip in Mortal Combat Arts two
people are gonna be stepping out here in
a second I'm wondering from hell we
gonna get me to fight John again John
was here since the beginning so we might
as well we also have a similar win
rating possibility all right Mike wolf
human male says feels like they really
want to respect Native American culture
with night wolf really cool to see on a
game like MK I'm yeah I'm curious how
how Native Americans feel about my
wolves representation yeah I was gonna
say in this yeah I think since they put
I forget his his name in killer instinct
where like they actually they consulted
I remember that I remember that about
like actual feedback on how they should
like dress them up and publish right so
you would assume that then another round
would also want to take similar care I
mean III think they also have the
advantage of this game where it just it
looks really good like to the characters
look very almost like photorealistic so
I feel like you have to do a better job
just making that character look accurate
to like Native American ethnicity but
yeah I would you know I would love to
see that because yes Bob Jones pointed
out and I think in one of the previous
oh no I can't believe this and won the
previous MK games night wolf was not
well-received so I would love to know
what people think about in this one
Emanuel from Puerto Rico says love you
guys thank you fortunately you're coming
in kind of the end of the stream we got
about six minutes left we also got a
boot it out of our own Lobby again we're
doing so well for most of the stream
Yeah right
dang
I know it's not gonna work
coffin cat says as a half native I
approve of night wolf and have since the
90s cool I mean everyone's gonna have
their own
I think opinion know of how they feel
about it but that's okay but what ya
can't join man enough time doesn't do it
we have a tough time for one more match
no this won't do I'll make a new a new
room yeah okay I'm making a new room and
the first person who comes in
that's who will fight that'll be our
last fight okay I'm gonna go ahead and
get rid of that text then all right so
the room name is GameSpot come in and
get your free weigh-in
fail the crate room nevermind maybe that
room is still there so let's do GG a
okay spot cuz they're always good games
the game shouldn't put you guys out of
your own room if a player rage quits
yeah I'm not sure if it was a ragequit
or there's a connection issue more than
anything else it's not can run at
setting is garbage it's not the getting
booted baton let's do it
let's do a man it's not the getting
booted that annoys me the most it's the
you can't rejoin that room also John I
think I'm gonna I'm gonna give you my
Johnny Cage - I'm let's let's go with
our best characters for the time says
you should change the T to a 7 oh I
should see we keep the leaps leads me
thing going up
we got the Jade back you gotta just
change the O to a zero could have done
that maybe that I've been too subtle
OS to the five they're gonna change that
do the whole thing in lead speak ma'am
all right is it the last one 99 crimes
O's s with uh with the money money ass
there's so many options man so much
potential I didn't do that I think you
did though oh I'm not good with Jade but
Jade is a good character that's my move
I love it
the sunglass is such a troll thing okay
I'm the star sorry I couldn't join I
promise trying to play a game with him
no worries man thank you thank you for
thank you for thinking about it well
like we said this isn't the last time
playing Mortal Kombat so not the last
time we playing games with you guys so
you can always always catch us every
Friday yeah every Friday we try and play
games with you guys we try and pick
games that that make the most sense and
work and then one there's nothing
available we just pick a fighting game
because we like to play it's what we end
up playing like in the office when we're
hanging out together anyway yeah I still
I still love that we've got like though
like we're not necessarily good at
fighting games but we care about them if
I just stop the fatal blow with the
sunglasses game play it yeah that's sort
of our mo it's like hi we're not good at
fighting games but we really like them a
lot and we have fun playing there with
you guys can I can I please hello there
we go
do you guys ever do MK on Xbox on
Fridays we give us owned it on Xbox
we've been sticking with ps4
see man I'm just waiting for that cross
save our cross play future because that
will solve the problem in a solve Olli
it'll it'll solve all these issues
imagine the day we get to go and start
up a room immortal no disconnection
everyone can join PC switch ps4 Xbox so
we're all able to hang out just have a
good time I'd be great I would love that
but yeah that was the last match that
was it yeah thank you for playing with
us everyone yeah thank you for all the
mercies and all the understanding woof
is a pretty fun character to play I
don't know if I'm gonna I'm gonna stick
with them I they're they've never been
like my go-to I've always right same but
he seems pretty pretty good people seem
to like him a lot which is cool
this this iteration is really read and
I'm really done with it I can't wait to
see more of the characters coming in a
more combat indeed but yeah thanks for
joining us guys we'll be back next week
with something not sure what yet but
we'll figure it out will we try and like
we've been trying recently to post on
the community post section of our
youtube channel that'll let you guys
know ahead of time what we're playing
goob yes I'll go give ed senpai a hug
absolutely thanks for joining us guys
and we will see you next week goodbye
everybody miss you
[Music]